si les mains avec donc un film phénomène
le rassemblement de quelques une des
actrices les plus en vogue pour une
comédie policière et loufoque huit
femmes de françois ozon
au croisement d'agatha christie et du
grand guignol deux des vedettes du film
sont avec nous ce soir fanny ardant
catherine deneuve
merci d'abord propose de découvrir avec
nous la présentation du film
marie-jo jouant à la location huit des
plus belles actrices françaises un
casting rêvé par un jeune réalisateur de
34 ans au nom prédestiné françois ozon
une maison bourgeoise isolé en pleine
campagne à l'intérieur le corps d'un
homme assassiné et huit femmes mères
épouses filles et soeurs ou bonne parmi
elles une coupable
un scénario comme un jeu de cluedo
efficace je me suis rendu compte que le
projet serait beaucoup plus intéressant
avec des actrices très connue parce que
le film pouvait ainsi être lu à
plusieurs niveaux à la fois comme un
film une intrigue policière à la gaîté
christique tout le monde peut suivre
mais en même temps ça devenait un film
sur les femmes et sur les actrices en
trêve ne pas se fier aux apparences le
tournage a été démocratique et chacune
égratigné de la même façon j'avais
construit avec chacune un lien
particulier est le fait d avoir toutes
ensemble je me suis dit je me coupant 8
comment je vais faire
donc j'ai un peu paniqué et puis petit à
petit les choses se sont mis en place
voilà alors sur ce film fait j'étais un
peu plus autoritaire que les films
président parce qu'il fallait pas fait
pas que je perde le pouvoir même
génération confondue par les secrets de
famille séduction ou ambiguïté sexuelle
ozon avec un ironique tendre et décalé
explore l'âme féminine
les couleurs sont en technicolor pour le
kitsch de l'époque et les stars un peu
moins star champ d'étude des années 60
philibert de quoi le confondant le jour
elle
oh